visa étudiant oui ben ameur france fred
dessine j'habite en face je trouve
panique pour le concours va bien je te
frère sa détente non je crois pas de
saveur des lecteurs vous ne vous êtes
pas présentés au concours vous êtes dans
l'obligation de quitter territoire
tu veux bien me poser ses 15 mai laurent
oh
où vais-je bien épouser je sais pas
comment vous remercie
pardon fred pu épouser mon pote quoi
ouais ça va en fait j'ai un truc à
l'annoncé d'accords pour te marier alors
oui mais je vous déclare mari et mari
l'agent préfectoral vu ça c'est un
mariage blanc tous les projets en commun
j'aimerais être enceinte
[Musique]
ils méritent des trucs de dingue en ce
moment en train de la grille
[Musique]
c'est pas possible ça va trop loin comme
on me jetait dans ton mari en plus